hey nicht wundern dass ich in diesem
keller bin ich baue heute etwas bestimmt
sich schon im titel das video heute
dreht sich um dieses tolle produkt ich
möchte heute versuchen below zu sprechen
wenn wir hier mal ganz genau schauen
behälter steht unter druck kann bei
erwärmung der ersten von hitze heißen
oberflächen funken offenen flammen und
anderen zündquellen fernhalten wir
machen heute genau das gegenteil
aber damit meine kamera nicht kaputtgeht
wo sie erst mal kleinen kasten bauen in
dem die explosion stattfinden wird ich
habe vor das ganze zu machen die mich
auf eine ganze menge grillanzünder
darunter läge dann baut sich druck in
der flasche hoffen sie explodiert würde
sagen die idee ist so bescheuert dass
sie nur gut werden kann
fangen wir an den kasten zu bauen
[Musik]
so leute die wände sind gebaute nach
vorne die plexiglasscheibe daran dass
wir auch was sehen können und dann kann
es losgehen
so leute ich habe jetzt alles fertig
gemacht ich habe die innenseite noch mit
alu folie ausgekleidet
damit das holz kein feuer fängt
hoffentlich ich habe wirklich so lange
daran gesessen jetzt falls ihr das auf
irgendeiner ebene feier dieses video
lasst mir dafür schon mal leichter also
ich hab das jetzt auch ein massives
metallstück gesetzt und jetzt die
grenzen da rein und da kann es schon
losgehen ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt
als lustig ich tue es wirklich das ist
mit abstand das durfte video was ich
jemals gemacht habe und was
wahrscheinlich machen werde
aber ich habe jetzt angefangen und dann
werde ich auch zu ende bringen zur
kleinen erklärung ich hab so was früher
immer mit meinen schulfreunden gemacht
da sind wir in der sechsten klasse also
irgendwo im wald gegangen und haben die
dinge also den flaschen damals gesprengt
und jetzt mache ich das mit blau die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sollten ganz
vernünftig sein und ich hoffe vor allem
das nicht irgendwie das plexiglas vorne
zerbricht und mein handy dann drauf geht
weil das will ich relativ nah filmen
lassen wenn es explodiert ist es übels
um aber ich mache das jetzt einfach für
die wissenschaft baby weißt du dieses
video sieht ich weiß nicht warum ich das
getan habe aber wir werden jetzt sehen
ob dein duschraum explodiert oder nicht
what the [ __ ]
oh mein gott
leute ich bin der glücklichste schüttelt
hätte so angst dass das alles umsonst
passiert ist gerade es hat alles
geklappt
ja mal stoffe ist verbrennt ihr nicht
alles jetzt ein paar sekunden später
okay ich bin ziemlich froh dass ich
diese platte darunter getan habe deute
glaube dass hier sollte beweis genug
sein dass ihr das zu hause nicht nach
macht ist einfach für mich gefährlich
meint view selbst ist entflammbar also
der schaum alleine wenn man ihn nur an
findet das seht ihr ja das ist ja was so
stark brennt gerade da unten macht das
zu hause nicht nach solltet ihr meinen
kanal noch nicht abonniert haben dann
tut es jetzt
es hat jetzt alles aufgehört zu brennen
beziehungsweise verglüht gerade noch so
langsam meint es wäre so oder so nichts
schlimmes passiert der rasen ist nass es
hat gerade eben geregnet und herum
nichts was anfangen könnte zu brennen
und unter dem feuer bzw
bis dann halt auseinander gefallen ist
war die metallplatte ich hab gesehen
dass es verdammt gefährlich also macht
das nicht nach baby wenn du das video
sie ist schick mir bitten paket mit
jedem pilot ist es gibt diese idee habe
ich ewig mit mir herumgetragen ich meine
ich habe vor sechs tagen mal auf twitter
gepostet durch das sprengen will da
hatte ich schon das spiel gekauft und
jetzt habe ich es endlich vollbracht
guckt mal leute da doch das letzte
bisschen vor sich hin
ich analysiere erstmal mit euch was
übrig geblieben ist von der flasche ich
kann nur so viel sagen es ist nicht viel
glaube dass hier ist der flaschenboden
von der flasche
der ist aber auch hoffnungslos fest
geschmolzen der flaschenboden noch
ziemlich heiß logischerweise ist lag
dabei mein feuer
das hier ist wie gewesen also die
flasche zumindest darum sieht man doch
wo der deckel drauf saß das ist dieser
rand oben gewesen mein kasten hat ja im
prinzip schon seine wirkung erfüllt
indem er halt einfach ganz geblieben ist
bei der explosion hatte angst dass
irgendwelche metallteile auf mich
fliegen ich bin zufrieden aber ich mache
das auch nicht noch mal außer bei 100000
likes dann mache ich es mit fünf
flaschen auf einmal
bestimmt habt ihr euch aber auch genau
wie ich schon gefragt was passiert wenn
explodiertes bio explodiert und genau
das finden wir jetzt heraus